The sharks are back
in an all-new season
of "Shark Tank,"
where hopeful entrepreneurs
from across the country
dream of a chance
to secure an investment
and gain powerful partners
to start, grow, or save
their businesses.
I decided to revolutionize
the dessert industry.
(all) We can save lives,
and you can make money.
If the sharks hear
a great idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money...
I'll give you $1 million.
And they'll fight each other
for a piece of the action.
Listen to what he just said!
(Robert)
Kevin, why would they--
It doesn't matter
what you think.
I couldn't care less.
It's what they think.
But first the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
How can you come in here
and say,
"I need to get clear
on the numbers"?
I thought I had a good,
basic understanding of it.
No, you were terrible.
It's sink...
all I see is problems.
Or swim.
We have an order from
a very high-ranking
government official.
How about president Obama?
Wow.
♪♪
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran
went from working
as a waitress in Manhattan
to building the city's
preeminent real estate empire.
Daymond John is a fashion mogul
and branding expert
who grew
his homemade clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand Fubu.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious
billionaire entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas Mavericks.
♪♪
First up is Carmen Lindner,
selling a delicious new twist
on an old camping favorite.
Hi.
My name is Carmen Lindner,
and I am the founder and c.E.O.
Of gotta have s'more.
I'm here seeking an investment
of $75,000
in exchange for 25% equity
in my company.
Quick show of hands here.
Who likes s'mores?
Me, too.
But you know what I don't like?
Camping.
(sharks laugh)
So I decided to set out
and revolutionize
the dessert industry.
I want to introduce you
to the s'muffin.
The s'muffin is a s'more
in the shape of a mini muffin.
And I promise you have never
seen or tasted
anything
quite like this before.
You don't have to take
my word for it,
'cause you get to try some
right now.
Barbara, I want you
to remember something.
A moment on the lips,
a lifetime on the hips.
(Carmen) Oh.
(laughs)
Thank you.
You're welcome.
They sure look yummy, huh?
They are yummy.
Mmm.
So the middle one
is dark chocolate.
There's one that's chocolate
with caramel.
And another half that is...
thank you.
(Carmen) Milk chocolate.
Oh, that's a good one.
(Kevin) Carmen, it's gotta be
a million calories.
It's not
It's only 200 calories,
but I'm not trying
to market these as a fat-free.
And so now that you've tried
your very first s'muffin,
you know why my customers
are constantly coming back,
saying, "Carmen,
I gotta have s'more."
(Robert chuckles)
Okay, Carmen, what--
what are your sales?
My sales to date,
for two and a half year,
are $250,000.
And that's just within
local mark--L.A. market.
What do you think
you're gonna do this year?
This year, my forecast
is to do $165,000.
How do you sell them,
Carmen?
75% of my customers
come direct to me online
or they phone in.
That's been my primary focus
over the first two years.
Do any stores
carry them as well?
So there are a few stores
that carry 'em--
Local specialty bakeries,
wine stores.
(Mark)
How much do you sell it for
and what does it
cost you to make?
Costs me to make--
$9.34 a dozen.
I charge $29.95 a dozen.
We deliver
throughout Los Angeles.
And just recently, I was able to
launch the national shipping.
These are the boxes
that I ship 'em in.
So--
(Barbara)
You ship them frozen?
Ship them frozen.
5 pounds of dry ice
with a cooler.
How much
is that cost for shipping?
Shipping cost alone
is $54.
Whoa.
That's a lot.
Which is high, but...
stop the madness, Carmen.
Let's walk through this.
You've got a dozen little
shmuffins or shmores in there.
And I have to pay 60 bucks
to get them...
(laughs)
To my honey bunny in New York.
All right?
Mm-hmm.
That is, like, 10 bucks
a shmore.
That's right in line
with all my comp--
All my competitors.
Is there anything else
out in the market
comparable to this?
No. This is my baby.
I trademarked
the name "S'muffin."
I didn't want to just
call it a s'more
because honestly, it's so much
more than a s'more.
It's a shmuffin.
It's a s'muffin.
I get it,
but the cost
is freaking me out.
I'm just thinking--
What--what do you think
is expensive?
It's 10 bucks a shmuffer.
(Daymond laughs)
My target market--
They're high-end customers.
They're used to paying
shipping...
(Robert) But why argue
with you, Carmen?
And I'm getting--
You're doing it today. You're
selling them at that price.
Yeah, and--
Not that many.
You haven't sold many shmuffers
at that price.
She sells $165,000 a year.
Are you selling
a lot of product
that costs $60 a box?
Come on.
Yes.
That's crazy.
$50--
Am I the only person
Who says that's insane?
(laughs)
I mean, you fedex this
across the country...
you wouldn't bel--
Or you send your children
to college.
(Mark and Daymond laugh)
You choose one.
You wouldn't--
Like, think about that.
You wouldn't believe
the frenzy
that these things create.
This is
the next dessert craze.
All right, Carmen. I'm not
gonna invest in your shmagels.
I'm out.
(laughs) Sorry, Carmen.
What's your background?
I was an advertising
sales executive.
I was laid off
during the recession.
I got a severance package.
My husband and I
had always dreamed
of starting a s'more store,
and--
What?
I-I never met somebody Who
loves s'mores more than you.
(laughs)
When you say "s'more,"
it brings back
happy memories,
and people
automatically smile.
I see this all the time
at events.
They're like, "Oh, my gosh.
These are unique.
What is this, a cupcake?"
I'm like, "Oh, no.
It's better than a cupcake.
It's a s'muffin."
And then they taste it,
and then just fall over.
Then they order it
and go bankrupt.
(Daymond laughing)
They come back.
They come back
and they order over and over.
My biggest cost
was investing
in getting
the national shipping down.
Why didn't you just
stay local then?
Yeah, like why are you--
if it was gonna cost you
all your money--
'cause I don't want
to stay local.
I want everybody to be able
to have these.
I want s'muffins
and gotta have s'mores...
that's completely
different, though, than--
to be a national name.
That's a whole different thing
than trying to make money.
You have a huge market
in Los Angeles.
Mm-hmm.
And you've got
willing customers.
Why focus on
trying to solve a problem
that's not really
a problem?
This was one focus.
(chuckles)
I'm also now wanting
to start focusing
on wholesaling as well.
(laughs)
Carmen, you're so in love
with your s'muffins,
you can't see the dollars
from the marshmallows.
I'm out.
(Robert) Carmen,
you put yourself in a position
where you have to ask for
$75,000 from us
and give up 25% equity
to fix a problem
that isn't generating
any sales.
All I see is problems.
I see it as building
my distribution.
The s'muffins were good.
I'm out.
Your strategy is, uh,
s'muffin crazy.
So, um, I'm out.
I like nothing more
than a real s'more.
But when I tasted this,
it didn't taste anything
really like it.
So I'm going out just because
I don't like the muffin.
And I feel badly
telling you that.
Okay.
Okay?
But good luck to you.
Thank you.
(Carmen) It was just weird
that they didn't
go bananas over them.
It's almost like I was
in the twilight zone... (laughs)
Because that was--That's not
the typical reaction.
How can there only be
a dozen of them in that box?
'cause it's full of ice.
You're shipping water
across the country.
(sharks laugh)
in season 3, Donny Mccall
failed to get a deal
with the sharks
for his folding cargo system,
invis-a-rack.
I'm committed to making
invis-a-rack
in the United States.
(Kevin) Donny.
Yes, sir.
You can't solve the problem
we're talking about here.
I believe I can make it.
I know I can.
Let's see
what he's up to now.
♪♪
Things have been going great
since being on "Shark Tank."
Before "Shark Tank," I sold
$75,000 worth of product,
but it took
about a year and a half.
Since being on "Shark Tank,"
in about 3 months, I sold
$75,000 worth of product.
Coulda sold a lot more,
but I actually ran out.
Hey, Donny.
Welcome to Dee zee.
I've solved that problem
by signing a licensing deal
with a company
in Des Moines, Iowa,
called Dee Zee.
And we're gonna be marketing,
manufacturing,
and distributing invis-a-rack.
(whirs, clicks)
here we have some inventory.
Hey, this is awesome.
I currently have hundreds
of people on a waiting list,
and as soon as Dee Zee gets
production ramped up,
I believe
the sky's the limit.
Well, Donny, that's
the first one off the line.
What do you think?
Looks great.
Even though I didn't get
a deal on "Shark tank,"
it's pretty overwhelming to see
the product that I invented
in my garage
now in a manufacturing facility
being produced
by lots of American workers.
It's--It's exciting.
♪♪
I'm Yuen.
And I'm Peter.
We're brothers
from Austin, Texas.
And we started the sushi
revolution, how do you roll?
Great combination.
You got it.
Coming right up.
I'm the C.E.O.
Of the company.
I deal with
all the business stuff.
And I'm the C.O.O.
I'm on the creative side.
And I came up
with the menu.
Everything good? Yes?
Well, we both grew up
in the restaurant business.
Our parents had several
Chinese restaurants.
So at the tender age
of 8 and 9,
we both started working
in our parents' shop.
The restaurant business
is in our blood.
It's in our veins.
It's just what we know.
What can I get for you,
sir?
I'd love to have
that slammin' Salmon.
Slammin' Salmon?
You got it.
Together, we've created
a sushi experience
that's never
been done before.
Can you add cucumber
to that?
The artichoke.
Can I get that with crab?
We've allowed the customer
to become the chef.
So our customers
get to choose everything--
From the type of wrap
they want to use
to the rice
they want to use,
the veggies, the proteins,
the sauces, the toppings.
And nobody is doing
what we're doing today.
Getting an investment
from the sharks is critical
at this stage
of where we are as a company.
I believe our business model
is gonna be the next great thing
in ethnic food.
And with
the sharks' investments,
we're gonna be able
to explode this concept.
♪♪
Hello, sharks.
My name is Yuen Yung.
And I'm his younger brother
Peter Yung.
Our business is
how do you roll?
We are seeking $1 million
for 12% of our company.
How do you roll? Is
a fast-Casual restaurant
where you can get sushi rolls
made to order,
just the way you like it.
Before we
came onto the scene,
if you wanted sushi,
you really
only had two choices.
Option number one
was to go to
a fancy, sit-Down
sushi restaurant
where you had to dress right,
you had to smell right,
you gotta like techno music.
(laughing)
And, you know,
those can be fun occasionally,
if you want to spend more money
than you actually have
trying to impress people
you really don't like.
(chuckles)
So that leaves you
with your second option.
You go down to
the local grocery store,
you get a premade roll
made fresh "daily."
You just don't know which day of
the week it was actually made.
The quality is just subpar.
And because of
Yuen's horrible experience,
we started the sushi revolution
three years ago
with just one location
in Austin, Texas.
We've taken
the same food quality
you get
at a high-end restaurant
and paired it up
with the convenience
of the grocery store.
Unpretentious, good food
in a fast-casual environment.
(Yuen) So we want you to
experience this for yourself.
So, Barbara, we would like
to actually invite you up...
how nice is this?
So you can create
your own sushi roll.
All right, Barbara, whenever
you go to how do you roll?
Uh, the first thing
you want to do...
Mm-hmm.
Is pick out
what kind of wrap you'd like.
We have seaweed wrap,
and we have soy wrap.
I'll take the soy wrap.
Soy wrap. Good choice.
And what you get to do
is pick out your protein.
Mm-hmm.
We have crab stick,
chicken, salmon, tuna.
I'll take the tuna.
Okay, and we also have
proprietary sauces.
Wow.
Okay, do you like
spicy, sweet?
A little spicy.
Our best seller
is the spicy mayo.
I'll take it.
And I'll go ahead
and put that on there.
(Peter) You can have a seat,
and I'll bring that
right out to you.
Sharks, do not fear,
we have food for you, too.
You're gonna get to sample
our other side of the menu,
which is our featured rolls.
He's making it right there.
He's making it
right now.
Thank you, Yuen.
You bet.
Daymond.
Thank you.
Enjoy.
Mmm.
Thank you, sir.
There you go.
Good sushi.
(mouth full) Fantastic.
(Yuen) Thank you.
Thank you.
Hurry. Hurry.
Barbara, this is
your custom roll.
There you go.
How nice is this?
Yeah.
Mmm.
(Daymond) Very good.
This is very good.
So here's our question--
Who wants to roll
with us?
Yuen, how did you
get started in this?
You know, it's funny.
We both grew up
in the restaurant business.
I actually said,
"I'm never gonna be in
the restaurant business again.
I'm never gonna work
with family,"
'cause I had to work with
my parents growing up. (laughs)
Uh, 14 years later,
uh, here I am, standing
next to my brother.
Tell us about the economics
of the business.
Absolutely.
Uh, so we started franchising
two and a half years ago.
We have sold 40 total.
We've gotten
15 of them opened,
two of them
are corporate stores.
So the first two stores
are our own.
We opened the first two.
Since then, we've been
focusing on franchising.
Got it.
And the franchisees--
How long has
the longest one been open?
Uh, one has been open
for right at about a year.
And how are they doing?
What are the economics
of their business?
So far, so good.
Knock on wood.
Are they profitable?
They are.
What's the average bill
in the sit-Down restaurant?
Roughly, it's around
$10 to $12.
Sushi's good.
Let's talk money.
Yeah.
You're offering me 12%
of the corporate entity...
correct.
That owns
all the franchise flows
for $1 million.
That is correct.
So what is this year's
cash flow gonna look like?
Just on royalties,
it's $250,000 a year.
Wow.
What are your sales
in the corporate stores?
Oh, uh, one is running
600-something-thousand,
and the other one
is running $400,000.
(Barbara)
I would like to ask,
I'm going to buy a franchise.
Tell me
what I have to pay you.
Okay. So the all-in cost
of the franchise,
including the $20,000
in franchise fee,
the building out of the store,
buying the equipment--
$270,000, $300,000 all in.
Mm-hmm.
(Daymond) So it looks like--
now they're in business.
Yes.
But what happens after that?
You get a percentage
of what they sell?
That is correct.
A royalty.
What's your royalty rate?
Our royalty rate is 7%.
What are the compliance systems
you have
to make sure
you're getting paid?
Uh, we suck it right out
of their checking account
every week.
(laughs)
So you mean, in other words,
they have to set up
a corporate account...
that is correct.
(Mark) Guys,
let me jump first.
I-I like the idea.
I like the concept.
But that's
a brutally competitive area.
I don't want to be
in the sushi business,
so I'm out.
(Kevin) I-I'm looking at it
from a different perspective.
I believe
it's very well managed.
I think
your presentation's excellent.
And you have
the right combination--
The chef guy
with the finance guy.
That's perfect.
The valuation is rich.
It--It is probably
a little bit high.
We--we have had a, uh,
letter of intent sent to us
to, uh, buy 75%
of the company.
And, uh, that valuation
came in at 6.6.
Ah.
Are you going
to do that deal?
Uh, I-I don't think so.
I don't think you should.
Yeah, the reason why is,
because number one,
I don't want to lose
that much of the company.
Uh, really, honestly,
with the opening
of, uh, four or five
more stores,
our royalties will--will--
Will get us to--
to profitability.
What's your geography right now?
Are they all in Texas?
No. They are in, uh,
California, Marina Del Rey,
uh, we have one
in Phoenix, Arizona,
Tucson, Arizona.
Yuen, I got--I gotta tell you,
man, you--You started a business
a few years ago,
and someone's offering you
$6.6 million in cash...
Mm-hmm.
You'd be
a multimillionaire overnight,
and you're just talking about
turning it down like that.
We are.
Power to you,
'cause I gotta tell you,
the first time somebody
offered me a million bucks...
Yeah.
I--it took me weeks
to say no.
I understand.
I wanted to grab that check...
right.
And run.
(Yuen and Barbara laugh)
(Daymond) So, guys, the profit
that you make in food
is in appetizers,
liquor and/or beverages,
and desserts.
There's no money in this,
and you're selling fish--
Fresh fish.
I think that the margins
are gonna be too low.
I'm out.
Okay.
Great presentation.
Uh, more importantly,
great food.
Um...
I can't help you
with the operation.
I don't understand
this particular food model.
You're running
a great, great business.
Thank you.
I'll bring all my buddies,
we'll spend a lot of money...
okay. Thank you.
But we're not gonna spend
$1 million to invest today.
I'm out.
You have 15 locations
in 2 1/2 years.
That is correct.
Amazing.
Thank you.
I have recently gotten involved
in two different
food franchises,
and I'm quickly learning
how complicated it is.
It can be.
So I have great respect
for where you came from
and how far you got.
Thank you.
But I mistrust it.
I think your presentation
is so buttoned up...
uh-huh.
And for my liking,
a little too buttoned up.
So I'm gonna trust my gut
on this. I'm out.
Okay.
Um...
I like your business.
I like you guys.
Thank you.
So I'll make you
an offer.
I'll give you $1 million.
(Daymond) Whoa.
Wow.
But I want 22%
of the business.
And there's one caveat.
♪♪
Four sharks are out,
and Peter and Yuen
have an offer on the table.
I'll give you $1 million.
(Daymond) Whoa.
Wow.
But I want 22%
of the business.
There's one caveat.
I want a monthly distribution
prorated to the owners.
In other words, the partners--
Obviously, you are the majors--
We get a check every month
from the free cash
that's coming from franchisees.
Percentage
we can negotiate in the future.
That's the only request
I have,
and you get $1 million.
So you're giving them a value
of $5 million on the business?
Less than. Less than.
(Mark) Less than $5 million.
(Robert) Right.
And on top of that,
he's getting
a check every month...
(Kevin) Well, guys,
I want to tell you something.
To reduce his equity.
I bring a lot of value
to the table here.
I know this space.
Okay.
Not sushi rolling,
But franchise...
Mm-hmm.
And the economics
of investing in this.
I'll force
some disciplines on you
that you'll thank me for
five years from now.
Ha!
Can you--Can you elaborate
a little bit about
what disciplines you might
be alluding to?
(sharks laugh)
All I'm saying is,
the only covenant
I'm putting in place is--
is to make you
more money monthly.
I'm going to sit down
with you and negotiate
what portion
of the free cash flow
that comes from
the royalty stream
goes into your pocket
every month.
So it goes into you guys collectively?
L-listen to what
he just said, though.
But it goes into you
collectively, right?
Listen to what he just said.
He goes--
It goes into you collectively.
No, listen to what
he just said.
He said--Not only is he gonna
undervalue your valuation...
(Kevin) I think actually
what you're hearing here is--
Versus the offer you have.
On top of that, he's taking cash
out of the business upfront.
Mark never--Mark didn't...
(Daymond) But with you.
Think of this structure.
But he's taking the cash out
with you.
That's correct.
(Mark) it doesn't matter!
(Kevin) I said prorated.
But, Kevin, why would they
have a firm offer
for their business at 6.6,
and in their wildest
sake-instilled nightmare...
But, Robert, here's--
Here's what's great about it.
Take your value of $5 million?
It act--It actually doesn't
matter what you think.
I couldn't care less.
It's what they think
that matters.
(laughs)
(Mark laughs) No kidding.
I made you an offer.
It's very simple.
I'll be your partner.
I'm willing to give you
$1 million
for 22% of the company.
It's your vision. It's--
You still control it.
You don't have to give up
control. I don't want control.
I just want a return
on my investment.
Is that too much to ask?
I don't think so.
Are you willing to come down
on your--Your equity portion
to 15%?
I would meet you
in the middle.
Okay.
So you'd do it at 20%...
Yeah.
Roughly?
Are you not, uh, curious
as to how much he wants to take
out of that business monthly?
He has to have some number
in his head.
No, I don't. I-I--
to leave that open-ended?
Because you are actually
getting the lion's share
of what comes out.
That's true.
So I wasn't thinking
about that.
I was thinking that,
you know,
even if we got crammed down
with this offer,
uh, that we would still get
some share
of--of the distribution.
Absolutely.
So can we have a standing offer
so we can discuss?
Absolutely, Yeah.
Thank you.
Standing offer.
That's an aggressive valuation,
Mr. O'Leary.
I like it.
Of course you like it.
So all you want to do
is basically--
No!
All he wants to do
is protect his downside.
Exactly.
They're--they're giving up
their upside
because they think they
can get at least...
he made it sound so good.
A 15% return on their cash,
'cause that's what
their discount was
in their discounted
cash flow model.
I don't need your help
on this one, Mark.
(chuckles)
I figured this one out myself.
I'm not--I'm not
giving you help.
I'm just sayin'--
Yeah, the key
with these guys is,
I think they really need
the cash.
Do you want to punt?
I think so.
You want to punt?
Yeah.
Okay.
I think we have
other opportunities out there.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, here we go.
Before we answer, we just
have a quick question.
How are you gonna help us
with the real estate side,
which has become
very problematic for us?
There is no easy answer
to that.
Even when you have
400 locations,
every new one is a fi--
is a paramount fight.
There's no question
about it.
Right.
Those are
individual negotiations,
every single time.
Right.
Now you don't have a person
doing your real estate
right now, do you?
That is correct.
I am doing it.
Yeah, but, you know,
you can't afford one
till you're past 50 locations.
You just can't.
You're gonna have to do it.
Okay.
That's the answer.
That's fair, yeah.
'cause you're--
You're still too small.
Right.
You're going to reduce
your risk in some ways
by growing a little slower,
I think, whether you take me on
or not as a partner.
Right.
If I were you,
I'd take me on.
(chuckles)
Okay.
(Robert laughs)
Peter, what do you
want to do?
Okay. I mean, if you feel like
that's the right decision.
We'll take your offer.
Whoa.
Wow.
(Barbara) I wasn't sure.
All right.
Kevin, I even started
to believe that crap.
(Kevin) Thank you, gentlemen.
Thank you.
Looking forward to it.
It sounds like a great offering.
Thank you so much.
I'm looking forward
to working with you guys.
Thank you. Thank you.
Appreciate it.
Congratulations, guys.
(Yuen) Thank you, all.
(Barbara) Bye-Bye.
Thank you so much.
Appreciate it.
(Robert) Good job.
Have a good day.
You made a deal with the devil.
(exhales deeply)
Wow. That was amazing.
That was.
We took Kevin's deal
of $1 million
because ultimately,
we felt like
the strategic alliance
with Kevin
was gonna far outweigh
the other dollars.
♪♪
Next into the tank
is Bea Arthur,
whose business aims to bring
some sanity into the world.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Bea Arthur,
and, yes,
that is my real name.
(chuckles)
And I am the founder and C.E.O.
of pretty padded room.
I am asking $100,000
for 30% of my company.
The practice of psychotherapy
has been around for more than
a hundred years,
and it's helped
millions of people,
but it doesn't have
a really wonderful reputation.
See, when most people
think "therapy,"
they imagine paying $200
to be trapped in a room
with this guy.
(elderly male voice)
How does that make you feel?
(laughs)
Creepy, right?
So most of us tend
to solve our problems
"the normal way,"
by confiding
in a trusted friend.
(female voice)
Honey, you don't need him.
You need margaritas.
Oh, yeah.
(Barbara laughs)
She knows you inside and out,
and she's always there for you,
but her advice
isn't always the best.
In order to make counseling
more approachable
and accessible,
I felt we needed to provide
the credentials
of an experienced therapist
with the comfort and ease
of an old friend.
So I broke all barriers
and created
pretty padded room--
a nice place to go crazy.
Pretty padded room Provides
online therapy to women
on their own time
and in their own space.
We connect users
from all around the world
with an all-female team
of licensed therapists
through video chat
or a digital diary
for just a fraction
of the price.
As you can see,
pretty padded room
has transformed
traditional therapy,
completely redefined
the approach,
and is now poised to dominate
in This very important space.
So... How did that pitch
make you feel?
(Kevin) So, Bea,
I can go online
and get a credible,
licensed psychotherapist?
Yes.
What does it cost?
A trial session at $20
is a 30-minute session,
and it's either through
video chat
or our digital diary,
which is where--
And what are you paying
the doctor?
We--It's a flat rate.
So for $20,
they get $16 of that.
For $40, they get $30.
(Kevin) Yeah, it raises
the immediate question--
If a therapist can't
generate their own practice
at 150 bucks an hour,
They'd be a discount therapist,
and they'd go to your deal,
'cause they're getting paid
a whole lot less.
Mm-hmm.
So if I'm a good therapist,
why would I do this?
I was actually trying to solve
two problems with this business.
I really did want to make
therapy more approachable,
and most importantly, affordable
for the average consumer.
Also for new therapists
who are just starting out,
it's actually very difficult
to just hang up a shingle
and just automatically
get clients like that.
Is this only for women?
We're women-oriented,
but we have about 6%
male membership, actually.
It's a subscription-based
service.
There's three tiers
of membership.
$100 is
5 digital diary sessions,
and that's when you can
write in to your therapist.
It's an interactive journal.
$150 is 4
30-minute sessions with video
and one digital diary.
At $200 is 4
45-minute sessions
And three digital diaries.
(Robert) Bea, when I use
the digital diary
to write to a therapist,
am I doing that one-on-one?
I'm basically e-mailing her?
Or am I going through
your computer to do that?
It's through the site, and a lot
of people appreciate that.
It's a virtual office.
I've been working on this for
about two and a half years.
In our very first year,
when we were offering
free sessions,
and I was still working
my full-time job
as a domestic violence
counselor,
we did about $7,500
in sales.
$7,500?
Yes.
(Mark) What was
your average session price?
So we get an idea of the number
of sessions
that people paid for?
The first session
was free.
In the first three months,
about 600 people
did sign up.
600 signed up, and then how many
actually paid for sessions?
Um, originally, uh,
so our conversion rate has
always been right around 40%.
So people who try up,
about 40%
end up going on
and signing up for memberships.
The average customer stays on
for about three to six months.
What are you on course
to do this year?
$21,000,
and we're on track to--
(Barbara) But are you on target?
Yes, at this moment,
we're halfway through
our fiscal year.
(Kevin) But does it bother you,
Bea, that after
basically three years,
right,
you're talking about doing
$20,000 in sales?
I'm not even sure we're
proving the concept here.
I mean, that is absolutely
nothing burger.
(Mark) You've said
that the average customer
is three months?
Three to six months.
So what's the lifetime,
um, revenue value
of the customers
that you've had so far?
Do you know?
The lifetime revenue?
So in other words,
the average customer
is online for three months?
Mm-hmm.
How much revenue are you
typically collecting
from that 3-Month customer?
Between $300 and $500.
So your average--So--
$300 and $600.
I'm sorry?
$300 and $600,
I'm sorry.
Okay, so your--
That--That's a big range,
so it's hard
to get a feel.
Bea, something's not
adding up for me.
You had 600 people come and do
a session the first year.
If all the people
from the first year converted
into paid customers,
you would be doing
$60,000 a year
under
your minimum subscription.
Yes.
But you're doing $15,000.
So the drop-Off rate of people
that use the product once
and don't sign up is huge.
The numbers don't seem
to add up. Robert's right.
You're basically
in an e-Commerce business.
Mm-hmm.
It happens to be your product
is psychotherapy counseling.
It feels to me
like you need a partner
that can explain to me,
'cause you don't seem
to be able to do it,
customer acquisition costs,
margins, attrition--
Which Robert identified
you have a huge attrition rate.
In other words, people come,
use it, and just go away.
That's not--
That's not True at all.
I mean, our customers are
addicted to the site.
Well, then why do you have
no sales?
All of our business has been
through word of mouth.
But you can't answer
one of those questions.
Think about it. If you--
I--
(Robert) Bea, your--
Your numbers aren't adding up.
I mean, I--
they're just not.
You... (sighs) I'm not--
I am a non-Tech entrepreneur.
My background is--
That's your answer?
(huffs)
a non-Tech is a whole lot
different than non-numbers.
I understand that.
I'm building this.
The first two years,
it's been extremely difficult.
The learning curve
is very steep,
but I've learned so much.
And my vision
has been validated.
People are in love
with This site.
We get the--
it gets me high,
the things that people
say about this site,
and I get to help people.
I just need to get clear
on the numbers.
You just said it
right there.
How can you come in here
and say,
"I need to get clear
on the numbers"?
I thought I had a good,
basic understanding of it.
No, you were terrible.
(chuckles)
Terrible.
(Barbara)
Here's my spin--
You have a great thing here,
and I think it's creative
in a fresh way.
And I think it's--
Even has a noble purpose.
Right.
But you did a terrible job
fumbling through the numbers.
Ohh.
But I have good news
for you.
Hmm?
I'm terrible at numbers,
and I'm rich.
(laughs)
All you really need here
is to find the smartest
finance person you know
who has an understanding
of technology
and make them your partner.
If you do that,
I have no doubt in my mind,
you're gonna have
a great business.
But I'm sure not gonna
invest in it today
with that giant question mark
over the numbers.
I'm sad to say I'm out.
Aw. I kind of
felt like--Okay.
Bea, Barbara is wrong.
There are key metrics
to every business
that you have to know.
You can't subcontract that.
No matter if you hire
an accountant or not...
no, just get a partner
is what I said.
There are key numbers
in your business.
(Robert)
When you have ignorance,
you're not defensible.
You can't fight back when you're
ignorant about your numbers.
(sighs)
I'm out.
(Mark)
Bea, your vision's in place.
You've gotten all the accolades
of people who like your site.
You've gotta learn
the language of business.
Otherwise you got no shot.
And you've got
an opportunity here.
Don't blow it,
but I'm out.
(Daymond) So, Bea,
you obviously are doing
what you love
and you have a passion.
But it's scary,
the problem you're having
with the numbers here.
These numbers do not add up.
I'm out.
Well, thank you.
I do appreciate that.
I think what's appropriate
is a very simple story
that I think
you'll appreciate.
There's an island right off
the coast of south africa
where the largest population
of sardines exists.
Seals love sardines.
Hundreds of thousands of them
sit on an island--
Just bare rock,
nothing to eat.
They look at the sardines.
After about seven days,
they start to starve.
But they know
if they go in the water,
the great white Sharks
will eat them alive.
Somebody has to go in the water
from the Seals
to sacrifice their lives
so that the others can live,
eating the sardines.
It's the one
that's starving the most
that goes in first,
followed by maybe
a few thousand more.
The ones that sacrificed their
lives did it for a purpose--
So the D.N.A. of the ones
that live can go on.
So, Bea, do you know
who you are in this story?
You're the first seal
that goes in the water.
The purpose was that others
will never come in here again
without their numbers.
They will learn
from the blood in the waters
that you've provided.
I'm out.
Good luck.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Don't go swimming.
(exhales)
Let that be a lesson.
She's smart.
She'll figure it out.
(voice breaking) I'm here
representing my business,
and I really, really resent
having anybody call my business
or my project
or anything that I've worked
this hard on... horrible.
It isn't.
♪♪
(crowing)
I'm T.J...
I'm Jaiden...
I'm Emily...
I'm Kate...
I'm Paige...
I'm Bryeton...
and we're the inventioneers!
♪♪
Well, the name says it all.
We're inventors.
Look, guys. It's working.
(girl) whoo!
(T.J.) we created
the inventioneers
eight years ago
with the goal
of changing the world
through our inventions.
Come back here, you!
Come back!
When we're not inventing,
we're just regular kids.
We ride bikes, play soccer,
do homework together.
We're just best friends.
(grunts)
We've invented a solution
to one of the biggest problems
facing drivers today--
Distracted driving.
(all) Three, two, one.
(cheering)
(T.J.) right now our invention
is just a prototype.
But we want to get it
out there to the public
as soon as possible,
and that's why
we need the sharks.
(Bryeton) If we don't get
a deal with the sharks,
then the world will miss out on
one of the most amazing products
to ever hit the streets.
(all) one, two, three!
Go, inventioneers!
(cheering)
♪♪
Hi. We're the inventioneers.
My name is Bryeton.
I'm here with T.J., Paige,
Jaiden, Emily, and Kate.
We're 6 inventors,
ages 12 to 18.
Today we're looking for $100,000
in exchange for 15%
of our company.
(Paige) Sharks, as parents,
you unfortunately know
that this
is a very common occurrence
among teen drivers.
Stop it.
(girls laugh)
Teens think
they can multitask
and drive safely.
But they're faced
with distractions
like cell phones, makeup,
eating, drinking,
and fooling around
with friends.
Oh, my gosh.
(girls laugh)
(laughs)
No way!
That is so cool.
Now, sharks,
please join our teen driver
and imagine you are driving
down the freeway.
Put your hands up
at 9 and 3.
Now close your eyes.
One, two, three, four.
(bang)
In those four seconds,
our teen driver traveled
the length of a football field.
Thankfully,
these kids are okay.
But 18 teenagers die
every day in the U.S.
From car crashes.
The number-one cause--
You guessed it--
Distracted driving.
We want to make
a difference in the world
by solving this problem.
So... ♪ tada ♪
we created the smartwheel.
(Paige) We realized
that most distractions
require drivers to take one
or both hands off the wheel.
So we thought
why not create a product
that would alert drivers
when they make that mistake.
And that's what
the smartwheel does.
The smartwheel's
proprietary technology
tracks
a driver's hand position
and alerts the driver
through red lights and a tone
if it detects one of three
unsafe hand positions.
First is
no hands on the wheel.
(beeps)
That's obviously unsafe.
Second,
one hand off the wheel
is another
unsafe hand position...
(beeps)
because it's a good indication
that the driver is distracted.
And third
is two hands together...
(beeps)
Which is a common
texting position.
The smartwheel then
records the events
and can alert third parties,
such as parents.
Today we're looking for
your help
to get our business
off the ground...
(all) So that we can save lives,
and you can make money.
(laughs)
(Barbara) Nice job.
Thank you.
(Mark)
guys, to get it rolling,
is it a prototype or is it
a product right now?
It's a prototype
right now.
The first thing we're
gonna do
with the $100,000
is take approximately
$75,000 of it,
um, and complete what we call
the final industrial design
for manufacturing.
We'll then use the remainder to
start our first production run.
How are you gonna sell it?
We plan on selling it
on the internet.
Uh, we are open to going into
the big-Box stores eventually.
And for how much?
So we were planning on
retailing the smartwheel
for $200.
For cost to make it,
we have professional estimates
that say $50.
Let me ask you a question.
You showed us all the activities
that teens shouldn't be doing.
How does the device actually
stop them from doing it?
It doesn't.
It just records it.
You don't see a problem
with that?
And let me suggest
a modification.
Let's say
they're sitting there,
they take
a hand off the wheel.
They get a 120-volt shock.
(all laugh)
Maybe that's gonna work,
but I--
It's not stopping anybody from
doing all of these bad things.
It's just recording
the event.
Guys, have you
demonstrated anywhere
or put it in use for trials
or anything like that?
Actually, one of
the first things we did, too,
once we came up
with the idea,
was to do a pilot study.
You want to talk more
about that, Bryeton?
At that pilot study,
90% of the pa--
No, tell 'em where--
Where we did it at.
At M.I.T.
90% of the participants
said that
the smartwheel
would be effective
at changing
the driver's unsafe behavior.
We had an order
from a very high-ranking
government official.
Do you want me to tell you
who he is?
(Mark) Sure.
How about president obama?
We actually were invited
to the White house
to present to him,
and he loved the smartwheel
so much
that he wants one
for his daughters
when they're old enough
to drive.
Wow.
I would love to be part
of this.
But honestly, the challenge is
that I know absolutely nothing
about this space.
I know manufacturing,
but I don't know
electronic manufacturing.
I can't offer you any value.
I'm out.
(Barbara)
I'm picturing myself
introducing this
to my 17-year-old son.
One pitch is, "Hey, This is
gonna help you drive safe,
"and we're gonna get a report
if you take your hands
off the wheel."
That thing
ain't going on that car.
If it's going on,
it's gonna come off quickly.
I think you've gone
too far with the product.
I think you have to eliminate
the report back to the parent.
(Paige) But if we don't have
the reporting,
then there's no incentive
for the teen to actually...
Actually, yeah,
can I--can I--
work with the lights.
No, you know what?
I don't agree with you.
I think teenagers
do want to be safe,
But they don't want their ma
and their father looking over
their shoulder all the time.
Right. You're--You're mi--
They want to get away.
But then I do want to
bring up the numbers
from our surveys that,
you know,
85% of them said--
Teens agreed--
Teens should use
the smartwheel and--
I'm not convinced. I'm out.
(Kevin)
Here's my take on this--
You've achieved a whole lot,
putting this
whole thing together.
You've taken an idea and gone
all the way to the White House.
That's cool.
Now if you only had
a good idea,
just think
what you'd be doing.
You will one day come up
with a good product
that I can invest in,
and when that day comes,
you're invited
back through those doors,
and I will write you a check.
But today, no. I'm out.
♪♪
Three sharks are out.
To get a deal,
the inventioneers need an offer
from Robert or Mark.
(Robert)
Here's where I'm at--
I love cars, I race cars,
I know
all the car company guys,
and most importantly,
I have a 16-year-old daughter
who just started to drive.
I can't believe
this isn't an option
within an existing car.
Where I'm struggling
a little bit is,
I think you're missing
the business that you're in.
You think you're
in the smartwheel business,
But the name of your company
or of you guys
is the inventioneers.
The smartwheel is simply
a product that you've invented.
The thing to do
with a great invention
is now go and sell it
to somebody.
I think trying to manufacture it
and doing all this other stuff
is just crazy.
We did get, uh, another offer
to do a pilot study.
We were actually able to talk
with the U.S. Secretary
of Transportation Ray Lahood.
He not only endorsed
the smartwheel,
but he also offered
to set us up
for a pilot study
on Mass transit vehicles.
So what was the follow-up
to that?
The follow-up is,
we need more smartwheels
to test it with.
(Robert) Here's what
I'm willing to do.
I'll give you the $100,000
for 30%...
contingent on
taking it to a car company
and them being interested
in moving forward
with a licensing deal.
Was anyone willing
to go in on that deal?
What am I,
chopped liver to you?
No, you are awesome.
My offer's not good enough?
We are--we are on the edge
of our seats here.
Robert,
I'll go in with you 50/50
if you take out the contingency
on the car companies,
because I think once we go
visit the car companies,
and we've talked to them
not just about
driver training for kids
but also
the commercial applications,
we have the opportunity
to pivot.
My only issue is,
T.J.'s vision is to take...
I agree. I-I agree.
The entire $100,000
to manufacture.
I don't want to do that.
No, I--Okay, so, T.J.,
would you be open to,
once we discuss everything...
Mm-hmm.
If the best course of action
is not necessarily
to take that further along
But talk to the car companies,
let them help us design it
so we don't have to spend
all that money,
so we have
a little dry powder left
to--to evolve and pivot?
Yeah.
All right, Mark and I
will give you $100,000 for 30%.
What do you say?
No contingency?
No contingency.
That's a deal.
(laughs)
All right.
Thank you so much, guys.
Wow. Great job.
Congratulations, guys.
Thank you.
Thanks. Congratulations.
Nice to meet you.
(Robert) I love cars.
This is so cool.
Here.
(imitates engine revving)
(inventioneers laugh)
(laughs) We did it.
(singsongy)
Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
We're investing
in these kids.
They're super smart.
I--they are. They are.
They're gonna do smart things.
They are gonna figure it out.
I agree with you.
They're fantastic.
But I have to also tell you,
I love the product.
Jaiden's crying.
(all laugh)
It's okay. It's okay.
(T.J.) Oh, wow.
(girl) Oh, my goodness.
I can't believe
that actually happened.
(Jaiden, voice breaking)
The sharks actually
treated us like adults,
and they valued our ideas.
And it's great to see
someone else
appreciate the smartwheel
as much as we do.
(all) The inventioneers!
(cheering)